on April 17th 1970 US lunar spacecraft
Apollo 13 touched down safely in the
Pacific Ocean Apollo 13s journey was
fraught with enormous problems after an
oxygen tank exploded causing major
damage to the spacecraft Chris Kraft was
part of NASA at the time serving in its
Mission Control Center coming up a Chris
Kraft talks about the Apollo 13 flight
and several other experiences working at
NASA mr. Kraft also discusses his book
flight my life in Mission Control
thank you for being here we just
finished up with some questions from the
audience I don't know if you heard the
last one but the intent was you know how
do we how do we deal with things that
might go wrong
and sir I think you're the expert and
probably invented the system figuring
out how do we deal with what might go
wrong how do we run the mission and
control or direct it and manage the big
team I wonder if you talked a little bit
about that and about perhaps the the
book that tells more about that and I
think you'll see some real questions
this is a very space oriented group and
things to be very very good for
everybody why do I think that what we
tried to do is figure out all of the
things that could go wrong and be
prepared to deal with them and we call
those mission rules and we wrote all the
procedures both for ourselves in the
astronaut and astronauts and call those
malfunction procedures so we each knew
what was expected of each other we
dependent on each other we integrated
the astronauts into doing the job in
space and we did the job on the ground
to keep them there and to accomplish the
mission a little different than you do
when you're at Cape Canaveral it came
from Averell when you're preparing a
spaceship and something goes wrong
you're trying to figure out how to fix
it it's a little different for the
flight control team because they don't
have any spares around in a spaceship in
those days to fix the equipment so we
had to try to figure out how to
accomplish the mission even though the
equipment was malfunctioning fortunately
when you get to the space station
hopefully you'll be able to maintain
those systems in space
and I think that we'll take some of the
hundreds of flights that Ken Cameron was
talking about in order to bring up those
spares I tried to write this book for a
number of reasons I thought that most of
the books about the space program that
you've seen have been written by
astronauts and they are fine books but
they tell it from a point of view of
flying the machines and how they were
trained to fly them I thought it would
be of interest to the country to find
out how we managed it how we developed
the flight control system and techniques
and ideas initially and also to surface
a lot of the very very great people
through working the program or during
the time I was there that most of the
country didn't know about but
contributed a great deal to the success
of our operations so that's what this
book is all about
I'm Kelsey and I'm from Dallas I would
like to know where were you when Apollo
13 had all their problems I was where
was I when Apollo 13 had all his
problems I was in the shower and mr.
Krantz called me within about five
minutes and said they were having
problems and I better get my Fanny out
there I did that as rapidly I could I
think I was there in about 15 minutes so
in about 20 minutes after it happened I
was sitting at a console which I had at
Mission Control watching mr. Krantz take
care of the malfunctions that occurred
on the spacecraft the first thing he did
was seal off the oxygen that was a wise
move because that oxygen was very much
required to save the crew when they got
back to Earth from Jasper Alberta and
I'm wondering how many flate how many
missions were you a flight director that
you were involved in I was a flight
director for all of the mercury missions
and the first seven Gemini missions I
was the director of flight operations up
till Apollo 13 and then I was the deputy
director into Johnson Space Center and
then I was the director of the Johnson
Space Center from 70 to 80 - while we
developed it and flew the first shuttles
hi my name is Inga RC and I'm from
Kimberly BC where specifically was the
Canadian arm built I didn't say that he
would like to know Oh Canadian arm was
built in Toronto I believe and probably
a number of other cities in in Canada
because I'm sure they had a large number
of subcontractors so it was probably
assembled and put together and tested in
Toronto hi I'm Katherine from Indiana
and those of us that generation remember
you quite well and we'd like to know
probably what's your proudest moment of
the whole your astronaut time Bobby
Knight in Texas maybe you'll come and
see him play basketball I had many proud
moments I'm I don't think I could single
out anyone proud moment that would be
extremely difficult for me to do I think
Alan Shepard was certainly a flight
where I learned to be a flight director
because and until you put a human being
on the end of a rocket you don't under
really understand the problem and I was
pretty nervous
I was pretty exhilarated when it was
over as was Alan Shepard certainly
Glenn's flight was a great flight for
all of us and then each one got better
Apollo 8 was probably my most
exhilarating moment because I was the
guy that had talked to management into
putting the vehicle around the moon and
then in orbit around the moon and that's
a little bit different than just going
around it so it had to work going in and
it had to work coming out and that was
pretty exciting and pretty demanding on
my heart I suppose
to the I'm sure the answers don't still
drink orange juice but I don't think
they ever thought much of Tang
here dr. Kraft my name is willow in
South Carolina who is the most difficult
astronaut that you had to work with on a
flight
I I better read my book it'd be a lot
easier for me to have you read my book
and I was pretty straightforward about
who was good who was banned who was
indifferent and who was the best I'm
Michelle I'm from South Dakota and I'm
just curious what your thoughts are
about civilians flying up in in space
especially after the Challenger accident
and the teacher what would you test for
about civilians flying in space
I still didn't it's a good question with
mr. Tito from who hasn't paid the
Russians 20 million dot or he he's has
20 million dollars in escrow he hadn't
paid the Russians anything yet that
means are so anxious to get him up there
I think if you're gonna go into space
you've got to be trained to go into
space and if you're not and you don't
have the right feeling the right
attitude the right things going on in
your head then you ought not be there
and I think NASA knows how to do that
extremely well and I don't think mr.
Tito who wants to go has been through
that yet eventually I think anybody can
go into space but I think right now you
don't want somebody that's gonna be up
there that you know aren't quite sure
how they're going to react and believe
me even though you may not know it there
are a lot of bad things that have
happened with people in space some of
whom were not astronauts
my name is Andrew Murdoch I'm from
Chicago my question is why is Mission
Control in Houston instead of here where
the shuttles are launched it's very good
question initially I'd have to say that
the the Johnson Space Center as it is
known today arrived in Houston because
of the politics when you have Lyndon
Johnson as the president and Al and mr.
the other congressman from Texas then is
Bay Parton and I was getting a record to
Tiger but Albert Thomas's of general and
I was trying to think of because Albert
Thomas was head of the Appropriations
Committee at the time and and certainly
we've arrived in Texas because they had
a lot to do with it and that's where we
ended up there were seven cities being
considered and if you had asked us to
rank them in the program we to put Texas
seventh after we got there we put Texas
first because I think it has been very
good for us but a more direct answer to
your question is when this thing lifts
off the pad you could be in Timbuktu and
it wouldn't make any difference because
from then on you're dependent upon
communications lines from around the
world as it flies either around the
world or out into deep space so it
really doesn't make any difference where
the control center is we wanted the
control center where it was after we
moved to Texas because we want to
deflate control people the astronauts
and the engineers that built it to work
together to build the best machines
I'm Rebecca Fox from Colorado Springs I
want to know about how many gallons of
oxygen doesn't person need for a flight
well it depends on the shuttle or the
space station it takes hundreds of
pounds of liquid oxygen and as that as
the astronaut before we said in many
cases you take liquid oxygen with you
for breathing and for using to supply
the power to the of a fuel to their fuel
cells and then there is a closed system
that makes oxygen out of water as the
fuel cells produce water so it's a
complicated system the directive number
of pounds involved I can't honestly give
you and I don't think anybody to give
you the total exact number of pounds but
it is lots of pounds takes about a pound
of oxygen per day per person that helps
you any thanks hi Chris this is Dave
from Chicago thank you for joining us
today
there was an intense space race it's
your moment in time what kind of
pressure did that put on you and your
team to deliver the results you had to
deliver well I mean I'd be foolish to
say put no pressure on us because it
certainly did but the pressure was good
not bad when you did particularly in
retrospect I think that when you all
have the demands of the program when you
have the demands of a goal where you get
the commitment and dedication that
from the people involved you you
actually get more out of the people than
you would ever got under any other
circumstances so that truly was a
wonderful experience to go through
because people were giving you 110
percent of what they their capabilities
were and their capabilities improved
every day as a result of that and so I
don't think that we saw it at the time
as being any great pressure we were we
wanted to beat the Russians in the space
and that was a very big disappointment
to us that we didn't but we also wanted
to beat them them to the moon and we did
that in spades so that was a very
exhilarating feeling but the time period
that we worked in the 60s was really a
great time and I for one knew it was a
great time and that was a very fortunate
thing because I enjoyed every moment of
it and I think everybody that worked in
the program enjoy it they put away their
petty differences and they worked very
very hard at getting the job done that
was wonderful
my name's Alex Transylvania and I wanted
to know how much school is required for
to be a director of flight director or
an astronaut how much schooling is
required in order to pursue a career as
like director or as an astronaut you
would like to
I think it takes more experience than it
does schooling I think that you get
fundamental teaching when you go to
college whether you get a BS degree or
MS or PhD but after that it's really
experienced in the field in which you
want to go in to my recommendation is if
you're interested in getting into the
space program and for that matter any
place you want to go in technology you
better become an expert in something
it's very difficult to become a manager
if you don't understand what it takes to
get a job done and you only understand
that by becoming an expert in some field
and there from there to becoming a good
manager frankly takes the six kins who
knows what he's talking about now we do
have another question for you sir did
you ever have a breakdown of space
before is that what you wanted to yeah
yes was that a good breeze have you ever
had a breakdown in space oh yeah yeah we
had lots of failures in space a lot of
malfunctions a lot of dangerous things
that happened that we had to deal with I
guess the pollow 13 was probably the
most notorious of that but certainly
there were many times almost maybe fight
that I had everything to do with where
we did I have a lot of malfunctions that
we had to deal with
why haven't landed on Mars yes Charlie
would like to know they had landed on
Mars yet because we don't have the
inspirational leadership in this country
to allow us to spend the money to go I
would be hopeful I would be hopeful
young man that if you really want to
answer to that question that you become
a congressman or a senator and vote us
the finest weight and I hope I'm still a
lot to spend them but I Devon
thank you sir we've got another question
for you back there not my name is Josh
and I live in have alien seas I mean
have astronauts in Amiens Joshua would
like to know if astronauts have ever
seen aliens there are some people that
say that but I don't think so I don't
believe in UFOs and I think that many
things go through my mind when you say
aliens there are a lot of people I've
met on the earth who are aliens
nevertheless I think that I'll give you
this as a better answer if if a group of
human beings or whatever they might be
came here from Alpha Centauri and they
were approaching earth I think you would
hear from them and tell them and they
would be telling you they were on their
final approach
and would you please prepare a landing
site for us and certainly I think that's
what we would do if we were going to ask
the Centauri I don't think we'd stand
out off somewhere and observe those
people and then leave
I just don't visualize that as happening
so I think someday there will be a visit
from wherever either from them or from
us but I don't think they've arrived yet
thank you very much we've got another
curious young guy out there with a
question what do astronauts drink they
drink the same thing in space mostly
that they drink on the earth if they
like coffee they have coffee if they
like orange juice they have aren't shoes
they don't like coca-cola they drink
coca-cola they like water they drink
water sometimes in the past we put a lot
of things in those liquids that made
them sicker than the devil but most of
the times they got what they asked for
now just one more question for you
I'm curious hi my name is DJ and I'm
from Pennsylvania um where did a food be
put where to eat with the food where do
they put the food in this patient well I
think that's a good question because
that is one of the biggest problems that
you have is keeping the astronauts
properly fed so that they're prepared to
do the work they have to do it here and
have the proper nutrition they have
large numbers of lockers before most of
them go they select the meals that they
want to have three times a day
they sometimes trade off on that between
each other but they're kept in if
they're necessary and in frozen lockers
if not in regular lockers and then they
have these plates that they use to heat
the food in order to make it much like
it is in a TV dinner here although I
think they're much better than the TV
that you can buy on earth and a little
more expensive also yes ladies and
gentlemen as you finish terrific
audience on the other criminal camera
dr. Pratt myself
thank you
no it probably seems a contract for each
of the books I need over an
informational special so give up -
you're right that big white building
there that is where you'll be signing
his book so we perform to seniors
property thank you very much and leave
it on